and as we see that uptick in cases
medical experts want to remind everyone
we are not
out of the kobit 19 pandemic just yet
our vaccination numbers are still low
when you compare it to other states
and some we spoke with are concerned
sasha loftis joining us live tonight
with more on this potential issue
sasha brainer city has really come back
to life and so many people
are loving it but others say they're
concerned as the pandemic
isn't over just yet i spoke with a local
medical expert
tonight who sheds some light on a rise
in infections
easy to see vegas is bouncing back
new resorts are opening and casinos are
crowded
good and maybe i guess badly since we're
not really
out of it yet but with all this
excitement comes concern
as covid 19 cases start to climb again
in the summer in las vegas people are
going to congregate together
especially as a city opens up which is
great to see
but again if you're not vaccinated
you're at risk of getting sick dr mark j
khan dean of the unlv medical school
says while
our state has made great strides there
are some warning signs
nevada's positivity rate surged to 4.5
percent thursday
that's the highest we've seen in recent
weeks nearly
all the cova deaths in the country in
the past couple weeks have been from
unvaccinated people dr
khan says getting immunized is your best
bet at protection
especially with the highly contagious
delta variant
the mutation makes it more transmissible
and more
infectious many we spoke with say it's
important to remember
the pandemic isn't over i did get
vaccinated but you know
you still want to just be just be
careful they encourage others to keep
safety top of mind for themselves
and everyone else around them get your
shot
they need to get a shot to be safe
dr khan also said it's important to
remember that even the best vaccines
aren't a hundred percent effective so
there's about a five percent chance
you could get covet even if you are
immunized but he says that of course
it would be in the majority of cases a
much milder version
of the virus reporting live in las vegas
tonight sasha loftis
8 news now